when you highlight often you really
learn to train your fear like a muscle
sometimes the height isn't the scariest
part sometimes it's the exposure which
is how much space you can perceive
around you my name is faith Dickey and
I'm a professional slackliner
so slacklining is the umbrella term for
all the different facets of walking on a
flat woven band one of these facets is
highlining which is walking a slackline
high off the ground one of the best ways
to train for highlining is setting up
slack lines over water when the current
is passing underneath you you
automatically start to fall that same
direction and it's almost like you're
not in control of your body and that's
great practice for highlining because in
high lining when you're dealing with all
the fear and adrenaline oftentimes it
feels like you're not in control of your
own body either
Chameli is a town in the Alps of France
and it's one of the places that really
drives me in highlining
what's different about highlighting in
the Alps is that the whole experience is
more intense being that high off the
ground you look at the valley below and
the houses are just tiny specks they
look like toys it's unbelievable one of
the high lines that I walked recently in
Xiamen II was on a guilty MIDI and when
we reached the top it was a totally
clear blue sky and we were surrounded by
peaks but during the process of breaking
the clouds started to roll in it was
like an acid trip walking the line I was
out there in space and exposure trying
to balance and the line was swinging
beneath me meanwhile these huge white
clouds were passing and the line would
disappear the anchor would disappear and
then it would reappear and there was no
way to control it I just had to hang on
the beauty of the mountains is awesome
and yet it is a landscape that demands
focus and respect Alpine highlining is
the purest form of the sport I can think
of